one of the things that human beings
underestimate dramatically is their
capacity to get great at something if
they're totally immersed in it totally
laser focused on something but as i've
coached the very high-end athletes in my
life the top business people and
entertainers i can tell you that most
people underestimate what total
obsessive laser focused really is and
what it looks like because you are way
more powerful than you know you are if
you went crazy psycho obsessed laser
focused on anything even something
you're totally ill-prepared for humans
have an unreal capacity to get great at
things even if they don't have a natural
talent for it if they're immersed in it
and to learn something and acquire a ton
of knowledge in a short period of time
as well society is conspiring all the
time in our culture to completely
distract you so you never win to just
divert your focus and attention look
over here look at this shiny thing look
at this tv show look at this sports team
worry about what's going on here in this
war and they get these different things
on television and our phones and in our
lives and just get us distracted so we
never get obsessed we never get laser
focused
for an extended period of time want to
be happy build a life not just the
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
some rich people success habits that you
can copy today
enjoy
habit number two define your values with
mark manson my focus in my work has
always been
value focused um i feel like
in the self-help and self-development
world
there's so much focus on success
you know
getting ahead in your career starting a
business making more money having better
relationships but nobody's actually
standing back and defining
what success is like is our definition
of success
valuable or not um
and i think especially in
today's you know crazy internet world
where
we're exposed to everything um deciding
what we're choosing to define as success
is a more important question than ever
before
so that's kind of what got me started on
the whole value question in general and
then when i started investigating it and
doing a lot of research and writing
about it i started to discover that like
basically
you know if you think of like how how
you define a person in general um
as humans we tend to define people by
their choices by their actions um
but then what motivates their actions
well often it's how they feel and what
what motivates how they feel about
certain things and it's their perception
of what's valuable and what's not and so
that's kind of how i drilled down
to
to this idea that essentially what we
are is just an aggregation of what we
choose the value in this world if i
value money more than anything else that
will come to define me through my
actions my behaviors what i invest my
time and attention into if i value
family
that will define who i am because
everything else will flow from that
yeah the things i find interesting about
values is people
often act as if they are empirical
truths like money is valuable or family
is valuable and they don't realize that
it was a choice often handed to them by
the way they grew up their parents with
their parents instilled in them and so
stepping back and recognizing that all
of this is a choice that you can
consciously decide what you're going to
value yeah and i'd love to hear your
thoughts on how the process works of
deciding to value something so if
somebody finds themselves in a place
where they feel totally [ __ ] up they
don't like who they are and they buy
into this notion that okay a lot of this
is being driven by values
how do they actually change that yeah
it's funny because i'm not a huge fan of
a lot of like kind of the typical
self-help tropes but the answer to this
question i think is kind of classic
visualization
but it's not the visualization that we
usually hear about so
what i talk about in the book is that
you
like let's say let's say i'm just really
superficial and i value money more than
anything like i've got like a fleet of
yachts and it's it's all i care about
you know um
and then something happens in my life
and i realize that
that's pretty superficial i should like
grow up a bit and you know value
something else and
it's not as simple as just deciding like
we've all had that experience in our
lives where
we wish we cared about something that we
don't or vice versa we wish we didn't
care about something that we do and you
can't just stop
um and so the the process that i
described in the book is that
essentially
before you can commit to a new value you
kind of have to like
try them on like like it's like going to
a store and trying on a bunch of pairs
of clothes
um
and the way you try on a new value is
you need to sit down and visualize and
you can even write it out if you want
but it's like let's say all i care about
is my fleet of boats and uh and i want
to try on a new value um like charity or
something
i have to sit down and start asking
myself what would it mean for my life
what would it mean for me as a person if
i didn't value
those boats anymore
[Music]
and that's a very hard question it
really
it messes us up because we realized that
a lot of our relationships would
probably fall apart a lot of our
business commitments would probably fall
apart um
a lot of our understanding of ourselves
would be shaken up or or questioned
and it's a very
difficult thing to ask um
and so
you know most of the times when you see
visualization taught in the self-help
industry it's like they take a guy who
wants a fleet of boats and they say
visualize a fleet of boats now go get it
and it's like no no what you need to do
is take a guy who wants a fleet of boats
and say visualize not wanting a fleet of
boats what would that say about you who
would you be
if that thing you always desired was not
your desire anymore
number three get financial education
with robert kiyosaki i really want to
talk to you about the most important
subject for all of us today rich young
poor old it's called financial education
and as you know our school systems teach
us nothing about money nothing
it's pathetic
you know they have financial literacy
courses today well that's not financial
education
you know it's really pathetic and what's
happening for most people today
is you know they follow that age-old
mantra go to school
what do you learn about money in school
nothing
get a job
while jobs are disappearing not only
that
is that with artificial intelligence and
g5 coming more jobs are going to be
wiped out plus with driverless cars more
jobs are getting wiped out so why would
you go to school to get a job
and then work hard for money but and pay
taxes taxes are going to keep going up
sports fans they have to somebody's
going to pay off this massive
mountain of debt stacking up all over
the world
and the only way they pay off debt is
via taxes
and then they tell you to
get out of debt oh god
debt is money please understand me in
1971 when nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard
money became debt
so the rich know how to use debt
to get rich
and that's what i do
my friend donald trump i know so you
hate the guy more power to you you know
but we use debt as money and other guys
will tell you get out of debt
well
you choose
the rich use debt to get rich and the
poor middle class get wiped out because
they're in debt
that's because of the lack of financial
education
and they tell you invest for the long
term on a well-diversified portfolio
stocks buyers mutual funds and etfs
the key word in there is invest for the
long term
why would you invest for the long term
when they're printing trillions of
dollars and zerp zero interest rate
policy they're paying you nothing for
your money
and you're gonna hold for the long term
and you got hft high frequency trading
you know they can they can trade a
thousand pieces of stock in a second
and you don't have a prayer you're
you're
you're trading against a machine
a robot
so all this financial advice people are
giving out there
is a recipe for disaster also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four have clarity
with dean graziosi every successful
person i know
knows where they're going
but if you if you just did something in
the next week just for proof of concept
over the next week ask five to ten
people
what they don't want out of life really
quick just say what don't you want it
will come out like a flow like you can't
stop i don't want this job i don't want
oh i don't want trump oh i don't want
hillary i don't want i don't want i
don't want and let them get into this
rhythm of sharing what they don't want
and then interrupt them and simply say
well what let me stop you for a second
what do you want out of life
most will say
hmm good question
or i have to think about that
so most of us are walking around knowing
exactly what we don't want and what do
we do we run right into it right
you know there's a there's a great story
i'm going to share right now that ethan
he always does these church groups and
he's the head of the youth group so he
takes 20 17 year old 18 year old boys on
this on this uh uh
white water rafting and they get there
and the guide's nervous because the
rapids are all number fours it rained a
lot the rapids were high and it just
gives me a a really great analogy when
he got done the guide was so nervous he
made the kids test like three times in
the first mile and what he called it was
the positive point
and the positive point was the the guide
said i will never point at a tree i'll
never point at a rock i'll never point
at the bad rapids that we can't get when
i point it's always going to be a
positive point i'm at a point where we
need to paddle our asses off and get to
so everything will be fine so just know
you're never going to see me pointing
anything wrong i always get a point
where we need to go
and what a great lesson for life
we don't we spend so much time trying to
avoid the things we don't want we run
into them over and over again
so
figure when your vision when you have a
clarity of where you're going when
people say that they don't have time or
they're overwhelmed or they're too busy
or they get just
there's too much complexity in their
life to me that you don't need a time
management program you need more clarity
on where you're going so you know what
to say no to
we live in a world filled with stuff
coming at us every second we got cell
phones and text messages and we're
available every second we have to learn
to say no and by doing having your
vision you get the ability to learn what
to say no to and for me
and this is from dan sullivan the r
factor question the easiest thing what
gave me the clarity i want to give you
guys this right now and again some of
you may have heard this before but it's
the easiest way for me to get my vision
instead of looking forward sometimes we
have so much stuff going on in our lives
right we got all the things you guys all
have your stuff
and it's kind of cloudy around us
because we're going so fast trying to
get stuff done some days we spend a
whole day playing defense do you ever
spend a whole day just waiting for
emails to come in that you can put solve
or something to come in your office and
talk like it's defense so we don't have
time to look forward so what really
changed my life about seven or eight
years ago on getting my clarity and my
vision is let's pretend it's one year
from today
you guys are back here we're having a
family reunion and instead of looking
forward pretend it's a year from now and
you're looking back
and it was the best year of your life
ever you're alive you're energy you're
vibrating you feel amazing you can't
wait to wake up in the morning what does
that look like
rather than picturing what your life
could look like look backwards on what
it does look like and let yourself feel
it when i do that when i look backwards
on the best year of my life i know i
know what i want to look like in the
mirror i know what my relationship
should look like i know how much money i
want coming into my bank account i know
how i want to feel with my courage my
confidence
i'm it's just a simple way to do it so
get the clarity of working backwards
habit number five love what you do with
kylie jenner i think i struggled for a
minute
with finding something
to do on my own and what was i gonna do
i knew i was passionate about makeup but
i didn't know i could have fun every day
doing my job
i'm kylie jenner and i am the founder of
kylie cosmetics
i had an insecurity with my lips when i
was younger so i turned to makeup to
help me feel more confident i went to
the makeup store and i just like
i didn't even know really what colors i
was picking i was just like i want some
lip liner that looks like the color of
my lips because i just want my lips to
look fuller but i could never find a lip
liner and a lipstick that matched or
even the right color that was perfect
for me
so that's where the lip kit started i
was so
focused on like formula and color but
everything else just kind of fell into
place
[Music]
i put so much love
into everything that i make and i make
sure everything is perfect and something
i would personally use so then when i
see my fans have it and they love it and
their reaction that's
what's the most exciting to me
starting a company
on my own
and it being so big from the beginning
there's not a lot of room for mistakes
every company has mistakes they learn
from them and they change them but it's
probably owning up to those from the
beginning
and just
being honest and changing them in front
of everybody
i'm the face to my brand and i take
responsibility for everything that
happens
i haven't learned everything from my mom
yet that i know that i need to she
teaches me something new every day about
everything she's my goals and i'm just
each day i'm like trying to take it all
in
she's definitely been a huge part of the
success of kylie cosmetics
if i could give some advice let's do
something that you love if you're
building something from the ground up
like do something that you're passionate
about
so you just have fun every day and you
love what you do and habit number six
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is beat procrastination with
brian tracy if you do the right things
in the right way you will get whatever
results you desire
[Music]
hello i'm brian tracy and one of the
topics that i can never seem to provide
enough information about is overcoming
procrastination
procrastination continues to be one of
the largest enemies of our productivity
and if we don't find effective ways to
break this habit it has the potential to
completely derail our path towards
success
in life every single person wants to
earn more money they want to be more
successful they want to have a nicer
home nicer car
more money in the bank
and no financial worries
and the key to achieving these goals is
to learn how to get more
and better results
i know that you might be thinking brian
i've tried everything i've set goals
i've created a time management schedule
but
nothing seems to work for me
this brings me to our first strategy for
overcoming chronic procrastination and
it's simply this
change your thinking i've said this
before over and over to millions of
people around the world because the
truth is if you change your thinking
you'll change your life here's a trick
for pulling yourself away from the
temptation to procrastinate
just say the words do it now
do it now
do it now
these magic words will motivate you and
push you to get started when you repeat
these words often enough the message
will get pushed deep into your
subconscious and act as a trigger for
getting things done right away
if you spend all of your time thinking
about how your habit of chronic
procrastination gets in the way of all
of your goals and motivation and dreams
then your subconscious mind will accept
that as the truth and that's how your
life will continue to be
if instead you spend your time thinking
about how wonderful you are at getting
difficult and important tasks done right
away
and how incredibly organized you are
with your time
then your subconscious mind will start
to accept that as the truth and you will
start doing more of those things that
overcome procrastination and get more
things done faster
so that's the first critical step in not
only changing your habit of
procrastination but also any habit in
general
change your thinking
the next strategy is from my
best-selling book on time management eat
that frog
and it is this
if you have to eat more than one live
frog
that's what i like to call a daunting
project or task a live frog then you
should eat the ugliest frog first and
you should do it right away without any
delay
it doesn't do you any good to stare at
the ugly live frog in front of you this
big task if you simply resolve to take
action and get it over with your entire
life will be uninhibited by the daunting
tasks that once prevented you from
moving forward it's important to
remember that you cannot manage time
time exists completely out of our
control
so you can't manage time what you can do
is to manage your life time management
really is just life management it is the
management
of the sequence of events in your life
it's the ability to choose what you do
first what you do second and what you do
later if at all
and in this ability to choose
lies your entire life
when you choose the most important thing
and you choose to do that first and you
choose to that that rather than anything
else you immediately put your life onto
the fast track
in fact you can actually double your
productivity performance and output in
one day simply by changing your order of
choices
in the way that you use your time now
let's talk about the best way to use our
time in order to move us closer to our
goals
the way to do this is by developing a
single-minded focus on the things you
need to do that will have the most
important and beneficial impact
on your life
right now whenever you're faced with the
task you must first ask yourself what
are the consequences of doing or not
doing this
and if the consequences of not doing
something are irrelevant
then don't do it
and do the things that have serious
immediate consequences
so here's what you should do each
morning to set yourself up for success
and
to determine which tasks you need to get
started on right away
to make a sizable difference in your
life
plan each day in advance take time each
morning to address your major goals and
then write out a list of things you need
to do that day in order to get closer to
those goals
set priorities on each item so you don't
skip your most important tasks and then
get to it when you jump right into the
workday and start on something really
important right away
the level at which you work for the rest
of the day
will be increased before we wrap up i'd
like to leave you with a thought to
share with your friends and followers
it is this
if you do the right things in the right
way you will get whatever results you
desire
now i'd love to hear from you so my
question today is this
what is one critical task that you have
been putting off
and what will you do today to start
working on that task
leave a comment below and i'll be sure
to follow up with you
thanks for watching and remember
if you want to change your future
take action and take action now
i actually i spent a bunch of time
analyzing and reflecting on why it was
that we were even able to do it because
all
like all reasons suggest that we
shouldn't have been able to do it right
because all these other companies had
way more engineering power and um
and and servers and time and money and
all this stuff and i actually think that
this is a pretty instructive thing for
anything that you want to go do because
this is the same property is going to be
true for anything that you guys start is
that someone else is going to have more
resources and be able to do it the
reason why i think we actually ended up
being the ones doing it is because we
just cared way more about it than
everyone else right so
there were always projects at some of
these other companies that were these
hobbies but
we always thought that it was this
really important thing and really just
like felt in our gut in our heart that
we wanted to do it and you know early on
there were always these skeptics saying
that oh this can't be a business we
didn't actually care that much about it
being a business early on uh but a lot
of the reason why bigger companies
didn't invest in it was because it
wasn't clear that there was a model that
would work for it it seemed like a bad
idea yeah and
i actually think that that's true for a
lot of the best ideas where it is that
it's not that someone else can't do it
they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you but i think often
that belief in the fact that you just
care so much about what you're doing is
the only thing that kind of drives you
to do it and you know to be honest that
kind of drives me to this day i mean one
of the the big emphasis uh points for
the company right now
is internet.org and you know for a while
we had this rallying cry of can we
connect a billion people um and you know
when we started talking about that we
thought that was crazy right it was way
bigger than any service in in the world
that had been built and you know it was
ten digits long right it's like a you
know it just it felt crazy we'd never
get to that but then the thing is as we
started to actually get closer to that
we took a step back and like all right
well our mission isn't actually to get
one in seven people in the world to be
connected it's we want to connect
everyone so it's um it's a big issue
that only around a third of the people
in the world have access to the internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early facebook we don't there's no
business model around this i mean all
the people who have all the money in the
world i mean it's not necessarily a fair
thing are already the people who are on
facebook right it's in the first you
know seventh of the world um but we just
believe really strongly it's like this
is what we are here to do um this is
what our company cares about i care
about it the team cares about it our
culture cares about it so we're just
gonna keep pushing on it and i actually
think a lot of the reason why great
stuff gets built is because it's kind of
irrational at the time
but so it kind of selects for the people
who care the most about it doing it
you've also said that failure was the
most likely outcome can you talk about
failure in that sense and in a broader
sense of being an entrepreneur and an
innovator why is failure so important
uh well i mean i think i think failure
is bad
i don't think it's good
but if if if something's important
enough then you you do it even though
the risk of failure is high
um
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome is is that it's not going to
work
and they should reconcile themselves to
that
past strong possibility
and they should only do it if they feel
that they
they're they're really compelled to do
it
you know
because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's the very beginning it's kind of fun
um
and then it's really hellish for for
a number of years you talked about
chewing glass
yeah there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur
and
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's
um
bully
said yeah you're starting companies like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
and
you agree with that
generally true
um
yeah
and and and if you don't eat the glass
you're not gonna be successful i worked
at mcdonald's i got fired i worked at a
furniture store i got fired i worked in
a car dealership i was fired six times
from the same guy i just quit leaving
and i've been fired so many times i
finally figured out how to get fired and
keep my job i mean really
so talent uh i'm i'm a sales guy because
not because i wanted to that was not
something i wanted to do
uh my dad my dad was a sales guy my dad
told my mom before he died tell those
boys to learn how to sell he knew he was
gonna die and he's like tell those boys
to learn how to sell and they can go
anywhere
uh i i didn't know that my mom didn't
tell me that until i was like uh 25 26
years old
and i had to take a sales job
she she wanted me to be a more of a
professional
uh so i went and got an accounting
degree got out of college there was 25
unemployment i didn't know it
i i you know i didn't know anything
about sales i didn't i didn't go to
college to become a salesman
but it was the only job i could get when
i was 25 years old it was be unemployed
or take this job selling toyotas
i didn't even know what a toyota was
this is this is years ago toyota wasn't
even
uh a thing yet
and um
so i took this job that i didn't i
thought it was just gonna be a temporary
job i said okay i'm gonna do this for
until i can get a real job and that
ended up becoming my career i actually
hated sales
because all the jobs i had outside of
mcdonald's were
part-time sales jobs i sold clothes
you know i remember selling clothes i'd
sell i'd sell an outfit i'd make six
bucks on it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
i had and i was trying to put myself
through college and
and pay for all kind of ridiculous
things i was doing at the time
and um
i i leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it i was just shooting
some material today for cardone
university we we have probably without
me over
um over promoting my own product we we
probably have the most
viewed
sales training system in the world today
and i'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer
this came out of a job i didn't want
and didn't like
but when i leaned into it and said hey i
need to commit to this thing because i'm
just gonna i have to learn how to do
this
i have to learn how to bring revenue in
and whether i liked it or not i needed
to learn i needed to learn the money
game the money game starts with
in accounting and it might have been the
thing i learned in accounting as i sit
here and tell you the story because in
accounting the top
i remember studying financial statements
in accounting classes uh it was uh
counting um the principles of accounting
i thought i was gonna learn how to make
money
that's not what they're teaching there
but i remember there was on a page
in the accounting book the blue
accounting book that i detested and
hated
there was a page about an income
statement and then they would compare
income statements to these companies
well the top thing of every page was
income revenue or gross sales
and later looking back didn't know it
then but looking back later i'm like oh
that's the most important part of a
company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top of the income statement
on every income statement everywhere in
the world it doesn't matter whether
you're in china or chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing gross sales
revenue revenue by department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much uh revenue is coming through a
country that is what determines whether
or not a household a department or a
company is viable
and i have been fighting
the top three lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
one
and it's called sales so once i leaned
into it boom i started making money man
it was it was literally that simple i'm
going to learn how to bring revenue into
my household i was 25 years old had no
money lived in a uh lived in an
apartment and my rent was 275 a month i
was late on it four times a year
every three months i was late because
i'd go up and down
and when i leaned into it i was saying
hey i made an extra thousand dollars uh
when i was 25 years old i'm like wow
that was the most important money i've
ever made in my whole life because it
gave me an idea that i could control my
income i feel like hustle is
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also your willingness to
get the job done like um kind of
navigating and doing what it takes
and um
and so i i yeah i've there's so much
about my journey where i was like i am
not going to let the outcome or my
success be contingent on other people as
much as i can control it help it
navigate navigated i'm going to
so
um
so yeah in the beginning especially
still now i mean obviously i'm hustling
i'm like at the at this where i am now
and i'm running around the airport
asking people to follow me on instagram
you know
i just feel like it's innate in me also
to a degree um but
the uh in the beginning ex like there's
a few examples that come to mind you
mentioned that i paid my i called my
friends and asked them to go buy spanx
and i wrote everybody checks and sent
them a check
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product's going to sit on the shelf
so i need to to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that my product was in the
sleepiest part of the department store
it was back in the corner and nobody was
going there so then i immediately
went to
target and i bought
envelope dividing dividers that you put
on your home desk and i ran around
neiman marcus and put them at every
register and i put spanx in them and
then i walked away
and
neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and um and i did
that because i had to get my product out
of the department and because i did that
women in shoes started buying spanx and
women in contemporary and and um those
decisions made such a big difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it because you
know everybody thought somebody else
approved it
um
it was so successful that the head of
neimans was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it i am mostly
titanium and steel parts this is me
artificial shoulders artificial
collarbone artificial knees full knees
artificial hip
i've been busted up over the years i do
a lot of extraordinary things
not the least of which getting run over
by buffalo
25 years ago
but i'm always pressing the envelope
physically
and mentally and financially
i.e we started the boxing ring which
uh as i told some of you in the
beginning 95 of everybody thought it was
a great idea 5 said that i was inhumane
like the gladiators and the lions and
all kind of bullsh and i've continued to
press myself
now this is a
2014 we're in new zealand and i'm i i
see a poster about um bungee jumping and
i said sally i got to do that and sally
says turn around and
it's right here this is where the bungee
dumps so i got to do that so
the next morning
i'm in line there's about 50-60
millennials kind of like you guys
and they're all saying the winds were
gusting 40 to 60 miles an hour
and you can't jump so all the
millennials will go
when that wind dies down i'm going to
jump that
i'm going to jump
they're all dancing around so i wait
about 10 minutes
i take a hundred dollar bill
i walk up to the head of the line
i said don't you think that the winds
died down now
he said i believe it is has sir
i jump
okay
i come back these guys are still saying
went out well did you jump uh
i didn't know the wind died down but
when it dies down the next time i'm
gonna jump
i believe with all my heart some of
those guys are still in line waiting
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more rich people habits for
you to try check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you guys are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother